hey guys I'm Louise I'm a staff writer
at Wired where I usually cover security
surveillance Amazon those kinds of
things but today I'm actually gonna go
off my typical beat and I'm gonna be
covering a scientific paper about a
brain interface which is a way for
people to communicate with each other
only using their minds our brains are
going to interact with the physical
world in ways that we can hardly imagine
today we're on the cusp of a cognitive
revolution brain interfaces have been
used to control prosthetics synthesized
speech and even fly planes but now
researchers are using them to allow
multiple users to collaborate with each
other so we're gonna do three things
first we're gonna read the paper and
break it down then we're gonna figure
out what kinds of questions we have and
try and find some answers for them and
lastly we're gonna reach out to the
authors of the paper and other
researchers in the same field
all right so let's get started with the
paper so it's called brain net a
multi-person brain-to-brain interface
for direct collaboration between brains
let's see we got here I read a lot of
papers for my job and there's always
usually kind of an introduction here
that backs up a little bit talks about
the topic more broadly because that
allows them to then explain how their
contribution is relevant here's a good
example here we have the first
brain-to-brain interface is demonstrated
by Rao and colleagues in 2013 so we
could look up those researchers or to
pull the bibliography out you always
want to kind of shout out other
researchers in the field they can
evaluate the research for us in this
paragraph they're kind of explaining
what's different about their research
those are good things to mention because
you want to contextualize this research
why are you writing about this paper
okay so now I've kind of gone over the
basic parts of the paper and this is how
their experiment works there's three
people and two of them are sending
signals to a third person about a game
of Tetris the first two people kind of
decide how they want the blocks to move
and the third person receives that
signal and moves the blocks so they can
not let the blocks stack on top of each
other with something really out there
like this we definitely want to make
sure that we have a paragraph really
early on in our story that talks about
some of the kind of technologies that
they used they
use transcranial magnetic stimulation
and EEG technology that's something that
we're gonna want to look up and try to
understand more about so here are the
results they used five groups three
subjects in each group and the accuracy
was pretty good eighty one point twenty
five percent one thing that's
interesting here is that they keep
making an analogy to social networks so
this is good you can see some of the
epic stuff in here those kinds of epics
things are definitely good to look for
in a paper like this because you're
helping the reader to understand better
the ethics considerations behind this
technology so that's almost it normally
have to read the paper the first step I
would take is getting some basic
terminology down okay so let's start by
learning a little bit more about
transcranial magnetic stimulation
alright here's an article from Johns
Hopkins okay so what uses magnetic
pulses which paths easily and painlessly
do this fell into the brain okay so next
we're gonna learn a little bit about eg
tech oh interesting so it looks like
Facebook is also working on something
like this I might be good so this is a
test that detects electrical activity so
we're just gonna make some notes about
TMS and EEG okay so now we're gonna see
kind of like what our readers might
already know about this what's already
out there about this topic so we're just
gonna type in brain-to-brain interface
what I'm always looking for at this
point in my reporting is references to
other things that people might have seen
because you never want to write a story
that feels really context list so they
really come away not only understanding
how that one paper worked but what they
should think about this field of
research yeah a lot of this is about the
Elon Musk coverage so it's good to keep
in mind you can add that to kind of our
question to ask the researchers like
what do they think of Elon Musk proposal
that might be something we might want to
ask
good thing to check here is I'm going to
look up Google Scholar and I'm gonna
type in brain-to-brain interfaces to see
it maybe someones written about this
Google Scholar is just like will accept
all of the results here are published in
academic journals
ok so interesting brain to mate
interfaces military neurosurgical and an
ethical perspective here we learned that
DARPA which is the research arm of the
US military is also working on
technology like this so that's a good
thing to note ok so now I have a little
bit of background to contextualize this
research a good place to start is just
the lead researcher on the paper so I'm
just going to look them up ok great so
we're gonna send him a message
and now that we've kind of got a little
bit more context we're gonna look up
some of the papers that we looked at
here to see if you can find some other
outside sources to comment on this paper
for us the monkey brain a very good band
name these researchers may be good
sources for us I also saw here an
article about like the ethics of this
kind of thing so another source would be
a bioethicists episode studies brain
computer interfaces perfect ok I see if
maybe there's at least one other one so
we can see a Duke the majority of the
research is on brain machine interfaces
so it's perfect we're gonna actually
look up the main researcher at this lab
journalist rely heavily on academics so
it's really important to ask them very
clearly for what you want from them I so
sometimes everybody emails a lot of
times now I'm gonna call a senior editor
here at Wired name's Sandra Robson I'm
gonna see if she has any tips or advice
as I'm reporting on this topic
so what do you think of ask them how
could you make this information like
have more depth
[Music]
yeah that's one thing I kind of liked
about this work is that they're not uh
opening anyone like jr. sort of surgery
or anything which is great yeah well
thank you so much dad I really
appreciate your help it's been a couple
of days and some of the researchers that
have reached out to got back to me hadar
sure how are you can you hear us yeah
this is Louise thank you so much for
making the time to talk to us today I
really appreciate it okay great so can
you kind of just walk us through the
experiment and I'm really curious about
why you designed it the way that you did
back in 2013 we demonstrated the very
first brain to brain communication
system and this involved one sender and
one receiver so that was the very first
time that I know we had demonstrated
that he could use non-invasive
technology in humans to convey
information from one brain to another
human brain researchers didn't stop by
connecting one brain to another they
introduced a third person and tested
sending conflicting messages through
researchers refer to as a social network
of brains and how would you define a
social network of brains like what does
that mean there's not so reliable and so
the social network of brains here
corresponds in a very limited way to you
know solving the simple tetris-like
problem but if you can generalize that
that would mean brains that can take in
what it needs to
ignore the other unreliable information
ignoring fake news tweets and the fake
brains that are telling us the wrong
information hopefully I think will be
great for you to explain is just how the
technology works like why are you having
the subject stare at lights right like
what is that doing to the brain and the
cow does that actually transmit the
information to the other person there
are several different ways in which you
can extract information from the brain
non-invasively using EEG so the idea
here is called a steady state visually
evoked potential or SSB EP so if I want
to select yes I look at a light that's
flashing at the frequency of you know 17
Hertz if I want to say no I look at
light that's flashing at a frequency of
let's say 15 Hertz and so when you are
paying attention and looking at a
particular LED that is flashing at a
particular frequency the visual cortex
it starts to respond at that frequency
to that flashing light and then we can
even recognize that frequency from the
EEG signals we recording doctor
explained that once the subject actually
focuses on a frequency researchers
detected using EEG signals which are
then sent to the receiver via a magnetic
stimulator attached to their head the
pulses are translated in the brain is an
image which effectively shows the
receiver something they aren't actually
seeing and the binary part is like it's
it's yes or no it's I see something or I
don't and that's the that's the binary
yeah the last question I want to ask is
what do you want to do next so there's
several different you know potential
future directions that we're looking at
right there you know right now we use
this yes-or-no answer based on some
flashing lights but then you know if you
use that tomorrow you can start to
extract more abstract kinds of
information including potentially
emotional signals also abstract kinds of
thoughts and so on so we're hoping that
you know we can start to get at that
kind of information which would then
allow us to potentially convey more
complex forms of information than just a
simple yes-or-no answer
and so we are addressing that also at
the center that I'm directing well thank
you so much for taking the time to talk
to us I really appreciate it
sure thank you so much thank you like
now we're gonna talk to a researcher at
Duke who's been studying brain to brain
interfaces for around 30 years he wrote
a book about a decade ago about this
technology
oh good are you can you hear us
yes I know that I'm about a decade ago
well I guess was in 2011 you wrote a
book about this topic and about what you
thought the future of it would be and
I'm curious about what you think has
happened since then and like where you
think this technology is going like I
know that Elon Musk wants for you to be
able to type without using your hands
and just thinking I actually find it
very amusing that Elon Musk is proposing
things that have already been done
everything that he proposed in terms of
what is going to happen we already done
it some things 10 years ago but I'm
hearing press to the fact that now you
have applications of brain machine
interface for people have lost the
ability to speak on throw devices in
remote environments there are too
dangerous or too difficult for a human
being to penetrate BMI is being used for
robot control and there's a lot of
confusion of whether you should really
use non-invasive technology versus
invasive technology invasive technology
meaning getting inside the brain and
putting electrodes inside the brain that
my opinion should be left to very
critical applications in people who are
completely disabled or cannot move at
all and obviously for ethical reasons it
seems a lot easier to be doing the non
invasive research I think that you've
done some with monkeys too right where
you can do a little bit more invasive
research than you might be able to do on
human subjects
yes in monkeys and rodents for instance
is very useful to do the invasive
approach because you are trying to learn
about the brain but I think the using
clinical applications and of course
other applications is going to be
limited by the ethical considerations
the risk and the cost you bring up a
good point which is right now it seems
like with these brain to brain
interfaces you can really only
communicate pretty binary information
human brain attributes they are
primarily analog and they are encoded in
a completely different way than you do
in a digital machine
so translating your emotions or my
emotions or my intuition my creativity
to an algorithm is not what happen we
haven't really figured out a ways to
produce or to deliver messages they're
more complicated but you're never going
to reach the level resolution that you
get when you're inside the brain is
there anything kind of about this paper
and
that you think is important to note or
some of the limitations how would you
think about this research as you know an
expert in this area I think is a proof
of concept this is an attempt to show
that it can be done to some degree using
a non-invasive method in humans the only
major concern I have is that we should
not consider this as a possibility of
weaponizing the brain of using this
technology and there are science to
control weapons right it's so great to
see these people who are paralyzed be
able to speak and communicate and then
on the other hand to see like DARPA is
interest in all of this it's definitely
really the opposite yeah does reason is
important to speak up well thank you so
much for guys I really appreciate you
making the time to talk to us thank you
I appreciate it now we're gonna talk to
a bioethicists about some of the moral
concerns that might arise with the use
of this technology so I wanted to kind
of talk to you about some of the ethical
considerations with these brain-to-brain
interfaces and these brain-machine
interfaces we were trying to understand
the phenomenology of being implanted
with a brain-computer interface so what
we will learn they're actually being
merged with an accountable device which
is linked with a an artificially
intelligent component can lead actually
to some radical attempt uses this means
that the patient and the individual
become very dependent and / brilliant on
the device right right and just like
more generally when you're thinking
about these brain interfaces and these
brain-to-brain interfaces I'm curious as
an ethicist like what are some of the
things that you're concerned about or
that you you think about one of the
first article that we're seeing is when
the technology is reading the brain it's
trying to select specific brain data but
in reality it's not only looking for
that specific data is also downloading
all the data it can find in the brain if
you will so that's mean that when you
have two technologies reading your brain
it's also pumping out some of the
information that you might not want the
technology to take in addition to
privacy concerns frederick discussed the
problem accountability what happens when
brain interfaces assists in illegal or
endangering actions either on purpose or
because it's a problem with the
technology
well thank you so much Ryder I really
appreciate you making the time to talk
with us thanks for having me thank you
very much yeah he's done the
brain-to-brain but he's also a lot of
brain computer stuff but that's like a
part of this so I feel like one of the
big things we learned here is that
there's technology they can pick up on
electrical signals that you could
actually send to another brain I think
some of the biggest things you really
want to hit and would definitely be the
future applications and the ethical
concerns and also where is this going
what are the things you need to think
about as this technology is developing
that's always a really good way to think
about framing an article so I hope you
enjoyed seeing kind of how a reporter at
Wired works it was really interesting
for me to learn about this topic that I
really don't usually report on
you